I'm gonna teach you how to network.
quick intro.
I used to work in tech recruiting for
like, 3 years,
and now I help produce content for one of the largest
job market places for people in tech.
so I pretty much get paid to
spend my days researching job search tips,
strategies, advice,
everything that's
gonna get you the job that you're looking for.
and I thought,
why not spread the love on TikTok?
The job markets not great right now,
and building your network
is probably the most important thing that you can do
to set yourself up in case you get laid off
or you need to look for a new job.
if the thought of networking makes you cringe,
don't worry.
it does to me, too.
I still get nervous before any sort of events
or networking calls.
but it's important,
and it's important for our careers,
and I know we can do this,
and there are easier ways.
the best way to start networking is to decide who
specifically you want to have in your network.
maybe there are roles you aspire to be in
that you want to learn more about,
or industries you're interested to see,
or maybe companies that you really admire
and want to connect with. or
maybe you're even seeking out people that have answers
to some of the problems you're dealing with at work
so that you can learn from them and make yourself
more indispensable at your own job.
you wanna kind of come up with a target list,
whether it's companies or specific LinkedIn profiles,
these are the people you're gonna reach out to.
don't be afraid to make the first move.
reach out on LinkedIn and introduce yourself.
I've got another video linked in the description
with the template you can use.
use the goals that we just identified. you know
the reasons why we want to talk to these people.
to frame that, ask.
most people are gonna be more receptive than you think.
remember, networking is not a one way street.
you need to offer information too.
so try and follow up periodically with
relevant article
or a tidbit of information
or to congratulate them on a promotion.
by taking this approach,
we're essentially curating our networks. you know,
we're filling our circles with these influential people
that are really
gonna help us get wherever it is we want to be going.